you are telling particularly young
people that the most interesting thing
about them is their identity and
possibly some kind of victimhood status
as well
[Music]
so last week at Warwick University
Minister for Education Nadeem zahawi had
to be hustled off campus by security
faced with about 30 students shouting
Tori scum and banging on the doors of a
room where he was going to give a talk
and you can see it online there's videos
of it
now that's normal
students are always protesting about
Tori scum and they're always banging on
doors and that's fine and I'm not
objecting to that at all but what I do
want to focus on is the reasons that
these students gave for why they were
doing this
so they released a statement
is the organizers the protest were
Warwick Pride society and they released
released a statement to coincide with it
and Warwick Pride Society in their words
is the University of Warwick students
union Society for lesbian gay bi trans
undefined and asexual aromantic students
and their friends
and undefined I looked up on the
internet and it's the label for those
who don't want to be defined
by labels so if you don't want to be
defined by labels you'll have the label
being undefined
so as this statement reveals the
society's outrage was not a Tory
corruption or sleaze or student fees or
generation rent or any of the other
traditional political concerns at the
left
the protest was because they believed
zahawi personally to be a reactionary
harmful transphobe and they cited a
number of reasons
number one is that last year zahawi had
come to the defense of the notorious
transphobe Catelyn stock in public when
I was faced with similar problems to his
at my own former campus Sussex albeit on
a bit of a larger scale
the second reason they gave was that
zahawi they said plays a significant
role in institutional transphobia as
education secretary for the UK working
alongside the equality and Human Rights
Commission
to produce guidelines for schools and
teachers on how they should treat trans
students
and basically
what they were getting at was that
recently zahawi has emphasized that
parents should be
he says front and center in any school
decisions about whether to change the
name or the pronouns of a child in their
care
so using language drawn from gay rights
the statement from The Pride Society
represents this stance of his as
endorsing the outing of children as
trans and accusers of how we're putting
children who are so outed at risk of
abuse and homelessness so if a
The Narrative is supposed to go that if
a school tells a parent that their child
has changed their name you will be
risking exposing to abuse and
homelessness just just like that
they also say that one in six trans
children who've been made homeless
were forced to do sexual acts against
their will by family members before
becoming homeless so they're trying to
link this elaborate causal chain between
a parent being told their children's
pronouns have changed or you know that
they want to change their presence to
some kind of sexual abuse
likelihood
um which I think is quite mad
and the final reason given for the
protest is that zahawi has in the past
made transphobic remarks such as using
the common transphobic dog whistle adult
human female
right so he's used the words adult human
female
this is a dog whistle this is
transphobic
um case closed
and so they say on the basis of this the
notion that zahawi does not incite
hatred is ludicrous at best
and they finish with the following
statement
given that transphobia is omnipresent in
society it is imperative for the mental
well-being of trans students
that the university make itself clear
that it is indeed supportive of
transgender individuals and that
reactionary harmful transphobic rhetoric
will not go unopposed trans rights are
simply not up for debate they are
non-negotiable
so that's the statement so what can we
learn from this statement
now I could argue with some of its ideas
and I do that in my book
um but I really just want to look at its
form rather than this content because I
think it's quite generic statements of
this kind come up in my life quite a lot
so I think we should focus on some of
its features and the first thing to know
is that there's a common theme
underlying all of the student complaints
in this
they're all about validating the inside
the psychological the inner right so
there's
um it is not even just about identifying
as the opposite sex anymore it's about
being non-binary or being aromantic or
asexual or
undefined or whatever it is
and it's all about my identity
psychologically
automatically should be recognized by
you and that is the demand
so when they complain against me or the
HRC or against the teachers who want to
tell the parents that something's going
on here or against a hobby for using the
word adult human female in every case
they're presuming that there is just no
circumstances whatsoever where it would
be not okay or sorry it would be okay
not to agree with someone's own words
about their own identity
now I want there's two things to say
about that but one is just how it
completely totalizing it is is just no
context in which you shouldn't
concede to someone's identity Claim
about themselves
and I think um that's very common like
there's just no core to given because
it's possible you could have a
completely different position which is
like sometimes we should exceed gender
identity claims and sometimes we should
say that other things are important like
material circumstance or how this
affects other people or you know there'd
be lots of potential things that could
matter there
on
you know I think obviously there are
cases and lots of contexts in which
inner identity cannot be the final word
on
um
entrance into female-only spaces or
sports teams or whatever it is or
children's identity when it's linked
into medicalization that can affect them
for their whole lives
but take the most extreme sort of case
like think I don't know some of you
might disagree with me thoroughly but if
you've got any ambiguity here it's
likely to be around I imagine Sport and
when you've got sort of obviously male
body people in women's sports teams or
putting
um male rapists in women's prison which
is happening you know if you've got any
ambiguity there you would expect some
Nuance in trans activist organizations
they might just say well okay here
there's a problem but no they never do
they never do they just go all the way
Stonewall like thinks that male bodied
people should be in women's rugby they
think that male body people should be in
women's prisons they just have no
ability to to nuance and I think that's
a feature of this style of thinking so I
just want to point that out
and the other thing is this demand for
validation of identities is so
individualistic
um does it matter what's going on like I
say at the level of nature or culture
even it's not about social social
construction in any traditional sense
it's just what's going on in your head
now
um determines how people should relate
to you and that's almost April
apolitical as far as I can see it's it's
so individualistic it's you know
politics is about
distribution of goods it's also about
cultural identity but cultural identity
is usually thought of as something that
um
comes from other people and how they
relate to you as opposed to you just
demanding that you get seen a certain
way
um but so this is an identity in that
sense either it's like in identification
with psychologically identifying with
some label and I think that that's an
interesting feature of a lot of this
discussion too how apolitical it is and
how it's not really um tapped into
anything other outside the self
and the other thing to notice about this
Warwick statement that I'd like to draw
your attention to is it's fundamentally
tied into the discourse of Mental Health
um so the Warwick statement says given
transphobia is omnipresent you know it
talks about the mental well-being of
trans students it's important the
university supports them the university
is positive as this authority figure
this kind of almost parental figure that
has to support them because it will be
bad for their mental health if they
don't
and they even include a quote from a
psychologist there is strong evidence
that minorities experience greater
levels of stress when their rights are
being debated says Dr Adam Jarrett the
chair of the British psychological
society's sexuality section
so that that
bringing in of mental health into this
area is a big feature too
um
in trans activism generally you are
likely to find the idea that um
debate or negotiation is a harm and it
will lead to then is claimed you know
increase suicide or other mental health
problems or self-harm or increased
exposure to violence so you will be
harming people if you debate their
identities
um there's also in this statement and
more generally the idea that um any
criticism whatsoever of the ideas is
transphobic like you just cannot
there's nothing you can say critically
about this that doesn't somehow indicate
that you are badly motivated towards the
people even if you say no no I'm I don't
like the ideas no no it must be about
the people and you are therefore hurting
them
so I think
this is cult-like thinking I think it's
um very similar to the sort of thinking
that you find in Cults where you know if
you read about cults the leaders tell
them anyone who disagrees with us is a
hater you know they don't like us and
there's always this attempt to like
get solidarity within the group by
telling narratives of paranoid harm that
will come to the group if you don't
stick together you know now
despite the
um appeal to mental health there seems
to me that there are kind of almost
structural Mental Health
issues within this
letter I mean it's extremely paranoid
and it's quite narcissistic
so my question is how did students end
up writing this document they're not
alone these
these statements are very generic they
come out of lots of Pride societies
um and other places
I don't think this generation is
fundamentally different to previous
generations I don't think they've you
know all had a random aberration I think
they're encouraged by institutions to
think like this and that's my point so
that's why I'm picking on this it's
really easy to sort of dismiss this it's
just like oh spit nuts but where it's
just students but no it's quite familiar
to me and I think our institutions and
the adults Progressive institutions in
particular I'm afraid are if not
um forming them they're certainly
reinforcing these styles of thinking and
they're not pushing back against them so
that's my theme really
every time a progressive institution
automatically defers to the ideas of
gender identity in its policies which a
lot of them are doing including
universities so in other words
they rewrite the changing room policies
to make them self-id they rewrite the
sports policies to make them self ID
they have they tell you know you're
supposed to do a pronoun round when you
go into class so every time you
practically enact this ideology you're
telling students effectively you can't
be wrong about who you are you just
cannot you know however you feel you are
then you are and the university will
make an effort to recognize that so
standard Notions from like philosophy or
just life like being self-deceived you
know not knowing who you are taking a
while to work out who you are maybe
being wrong for a bit right for a bit
wrong for a bit responsive to evidence
all of that seems to have gone like
you're just you are who you are right
now if you change then they'll they'll
Build That Into The Narrative so you're
just fluid but that's your identity
rather than just a fact of human nature
okay so we're telling young people if
everyone if you have a given identity
others need to accommodate it with
exception you think of stonewalls
t-shirts from 2015 you know trans women
and women get over it it's very
aggressive like you just accept that
and I think that this way of thinking
encourages a kind of arrogance about
your own thinking and about the demands
that you're permitted to place on others
and it discourages empathy like it
discourages thoughts about how other
people might be feeling in relation to
your identity and whether it might make
them feel
make me feel uncomfortable or it might
actually materially affect their own uh
way through the world
all your encouraged to think about this
style of thinking is the effects on you
um and then you've there's also the fact
that people are being encouraged to
treat any criticism as I said of this
set of ideas as criticism of them
so it's really encouraging a kind of um
victim mentality where you just keep
feeling attacked all the time except you
know and you can't really differentiate
the attacks and the ideas from the
attacks on you so you feel very
vulnerable
um
but it's also
um just shutting down debate quite
obviously and this is this is clear from
the definitions of transphobia that get
given so stonewall's definition of
transphobia is
any basically includes any failure to
accept gender identity transphobic so
you know everything I do in public is
now transphobic I would say it wasn't
because I would say that's a
ridiculously broad
um definition of transphobia but if that
that definition which is obviously
trickling through institutions through
HR schemes Stonewall has massive
cultural power in the HR sector
they will all that definition of
transphobia is reproduced on every
University website every Progressive
institution website you know so it's
going to start chilling proper
discussion these things then there's
also the fact that what is being in this
kind of style of thinking you are
telling particularly young people that
the most interesting thing about them is
their identity and possibly some kind of
victimhood status as well
so if you're rewarding that with
attention and I think some universities
are because they're frightened not to
then you reinforce it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas